Margaret Macmillan what does it meant to
you in your life that you're the
great-granddaughter of David Lloyd
George well it's it's it's been nice in
a way I guess to know that I have a
famous ancestor I never met him on the
other hand I it actually sort of
inhibited me from doing this book
because I thought I don't want to write
a book that people say oh she's just
doing it because of her great
grandfather and it's sort of an act of
filial piety so that's it's it's I've
had a mixed room and Devlin's feelings
about it really what role is it played
in your life not much in Canada in North
America but more in England where people
still know about him I mean I used to go
to England when I was young and my
grandmother was his daughter my
great-aunt who I was very fond of was
another daughter and so I did hear a lot
about him and occasionally people would
say to me you know things about my great
grandfather sometimes rude he wasn't he
was a controversial figure but in North
America it's meant very little most
people don't remember him today which
one is he on the cover of this book he's
the one on the left-hand side as I look
at it he's the one with the top hat in
the cane walking along then what man the
middle is Clemenceau and then of course
the man on the other end is Woodrow
Wilson the American president where was
this picture taken this was taken in
Paris during the peace conference it
looks to me like it's in one of the
grand boulevards that seemed to be some
trees behind I don't think we know
anything wasn't that what did you think
that this would make a good book Paris
1919 Oh years ago I've been thinking
about it for years and then it took me a
while to get around to it I think what
made me think it would be a good book
where all the people who were there when
I realized that Lawrence of Arabia was
the Queen Marie of Romania was the ho
Chi Minh was there an obscure chef at
the Ritz and I thought this is just such
a wonderful collection of people and and
I think historians are gossips you know
we love the gossip and I thought this is
just such a wonderful subject and then I
realized no one else had really done it
which if you're a writer is an
interesting thought and you think good
and so I think two things drew me to it
and then but to be serious well perhaps
a little bit more I realized that so
many of the great issues would discuss
there and so many other things we're
still dealing with will discuss back
then in 1919 and why was this book
called peacemakers in when it was first
published in Great Britain that was my
choice and I wanted to really show it
snappy title I think I was influenced by
Simon Shamas wonderful book on the
French Revolution called citizens and so
peacemakers was what I
when the Americans bought it they
weren't that keen on it they thought it
seemed a bit bland and my editor said
anyway she said anything with Paris in
the title sells really well in North
America so that's what we went with and
actually I have to admit I think it's a
good title and I love the cover what's
the time frame for this book time frame
it covers really six months in 1919 it
has a bit of what happened before and it
has a lot of what happened afterwards
but what I really look at is the intense
period of the Paris Peace Conference
which technically lasted for over a year
but the really intense period was when
all the world leaders were they and that
was from January to June 1919 now did
you go to Paris and go to the hotels and
the and the different places where
meetings were held into Versailles I did
I went to Paris actually to do research
which is not a bad place to go and do
research and I did see something of the
sites where the conference was held and
then I've just been in Paris very
recently the BBC are making a
documentary on the Peace Conference and
they rang up and said would you mind
coming to Paris for a few days to be a
historical consultant and I said well I
think I can fit it in and it was
wonderful because the BBC got access to
all sorts of places I would never have
been able to see we went to the creon
Hotel which is an enormous leap our
hotel in the middle of Paris where the
American delegation stayed and we
actually went to the Presidential Suite
where the Wilsons great adviser Colonel
house had stayed was really fascinating
to see all these places where else we
went to the Trianon Palace Hotel which
is now very posh spired and there's a
room that would have actually a plaque
on the wall which was put up at the time
which is where the Germans got their
peace terms we went to lloyd George's
flat in a little Street just opposite
the house where Woodrow Wilson stayed we
couldn't get into Woodrow Wilson's house
because it's owned by some mysterious
businessman who nobody knew much about
and he wouldn't let us in but we went to
lloyd George's old flat which is now an
office and the French people in the
office were absolutely thrilled they
were so nice and they said we didn't
know the history had happened here and
let us come in in film and brought us
cups of coffee every five minutes and
and it was wonderful we didn't go to
Versailles because the whole of mirror
is where the treaty was signed with
Germany's being redone but we went
around Versailles we went to a number of
other places I'm trying oh we went to
the French Foreign Ministry which was
fabulous and so the rooms were they
actually met what was the circumstance
that
brought them all to Paris in 1919 what
was the first date that they came there
and how many people were in that town
you know revolving around the conference
they're all around the conference I've
tried to count I mean there was
something like I think I forgot how many
official delegates each country was
allowed five or three so there'll be
about a hundred and sixty of those but
then every delegation brought a huge
number of advisers so I suspect though
well over ten thousand people when you
add up all the people who were there as
technical advisers all the press who
came all the petitioners who came
something like 31 countries are
represented and so you had a lot of
people they were there well they were
there initially to settle the first
world war and that was a huge amount to
settle because it covered not just
Europe but it affected Africa affected
the Middle East it affected the Far East
but because so many powerful people came
to Paris it was really like the sort of
magnet attracting everyone else so
anyone who had a petition suffragettes
for example or African Americans came to
Paris because that's where the power was
in chapter 27 its Arab independence I
just wanted to ask you and we're jumping
right in the middle of this but asked
you to put this in context
well said Clemenceau what what are we to
discuss Lloyd George replied quote
Mesopotamia and Palestine Clemenceau
quote tell me what you want
Lloyd George I want Mosul clemenceau you
shall have it anything else
Lord George yes I want Jerusalem to
Clements oh you sure have it but is it
is it pick Sean P Sean Sean will make
difficulties about Mosul Mosul was about
to become important because of oil what
is all that
did they really trade things like that
yeah they did that conversation has
always been very much disputed because
there's no direct record of it but it
looks at the French said it happened the
British said it didn't but what looks
like happened what happened is that
Lloyd George got what he wanted in the
Middle East and in return he promised
the French that he would support their
claims in Europe what George later on
denied this but what that conversation
was about was really dividing up the
Arab territories of the old Ottoman
Empire and the British and the French
had already done a quiet deal during the
first world war to do this they say
they didn't want the Arabs getting
independence they only bit funnily
enough that they didn't bother to divide
up between them was the Saudi peninsula
the Saudi Arabian Peninsula because they
didn't think there was anything worth
worrying about but what they did is they
divided it up so that the British were
going to get what became Palestine and
then Transjordan the French were going
to get Syria and Lebanon and initially
the French were going to have Mosul
which was in the north of what is today
Iraq and the British wanted it because
they suspected there was a great deal of
oil live and so Clemenceau much to the
fury of his own people including pichon
his foreign minister agreed but we
suspect that in return he got a promise
from Lloyd George to get some backing in
Europe but it was really old-fashioned
imperialism I mean the British and the
French didn't think the Arabs were ready
for independence they didn't think that
wish it should be taken into
consideration and so they carved up the
ire of Middle East really to suit
themselves by the way before we go on
where do you live now and what do you do
I live in Toronto in Canada and I'm a
professor of history at the University
of Toronto and I've just become head of
a college there I'm called a Provost and
so I guess it's like a principal and I'm
half administrator and half teacher
where are you born Toronto how did your
family get to Toronto well my father was
there for a couple of generations my
mother who was lloyd George's
granddaughter came to Canada in the
summer of 1939 as a school go it was
sort of a present from her parents for
leaving school and she was going to go
back and go to Cambridge University and
study medicine and she was in Canada in
1939 in the war broke out and she'd
quite literally couldn't get home and so
she stayed in Canada she went to medical
school in Toronto and she met my father
and never went back to England on the
cover these three men tell us about each
one of them start with your
great-grandfather Lloyd George there on
the left well George is a very
controversial figure indeed he was from
a very non-traditional background in
those days for British prime minister he
wasn't an upper-class aristocrat he came
from very humble origins in Wales and he
really was a self-made man he was
enormous ly energetic enormous ly
capable and enormous ly charming he
could really charm the birds out of the
trees I think even people who didn't
have any reason to like him would go
into meetings with him come out eating
out of his hand he was a great liberal
and he'd never been much interested in
foreign
policy that was one of the curious
things that he ended up having to do a
lot of foreign policy what he was
interested in was domestic issues and he
was interested in Social Welfare he
introduced the first old-age pension he
was a controversial figure the remember
scandals around him including a lot of
scandals with women but I think you know
I've come to think that he really was a
very great figure and although he didn't
have much experience in foreign
relations proved to be very adept at
that the man in the middle Georges
Clemenceau the French prime minister at
the time was an old radical as well
rather like Lloyd George although he
came from a different background he came
from a rather more aristocratic
background he was someone who had seen
France defeated first by Prussia in 1870
he'd been in Paris when the Prussians
had encircled Paris it was said that
when he died he wanted to be buried
facing Germany because Germany which
Prussia became a heart of was the great
enemy of of the French he's often
portrayed as vindictive and I don't
think that's true I think he recognized
that France would have to deal with
Germany if Europe put to be a safe and
stable place but he was worried about
German power he was deeply cynical in
some ways he said about the League of
Nations which Woodrow Wilson of course
was promoting that I like it but I don't
believe in it how old was he at the
peace conference Clements I would have
been in his mid-70s he was the oldest of
the three big powers I was like George
well George was about 58 59 and you say
that Lloyd George had a mistress with
him the entire time at the conference
yes well George had had a number of
mistresses he remained married to his
first wife and in some ways I think they
had a very good relationship I mean he
he went to see her every year they spent
a lot of time together but he always had
other women and Frances Stevenson a
young woman who came initially to teach
he was to teach French to one of his
daughters ended up by becoming his
secretary and his mistress and really in
a way became a second wife and she came
to Paris with him as his secretary but
clearly also was very much involved with
him we know this because she left a
diary and she was going to become the
second mrs. Lloyd George when his first
wife died in the in the course of the
Second World War she was a very good
thing for an historian because Lloyd
George was notoriously badly organized
he never wrote letters he threw letters
away his papers were mass and when
you came on the scene in about 1916 she
began tidying things up and so the
record gets a lot better after that how
old was he well George was late 50s and
she probably would have been in her
early 20s and how long did how long was
Lloyd George the prime minister
well George was prime minister from the
end of 1916 to 1922 and so six years
very very dominant figure eventually he
was head of a coalition government he
himself was a liberal but during the war
when things were going very badly a
section of the Conservatives recognized
that they needed a new prime minister
and so did the Liberals and so he was
put into office by a coalition and in
fact most of his support came from the
Conservatives the story of clemenceau
this is right in the middle it's just a
tangential story although you say that
you never chant he changed air was the
same again he got shot yep he got shot
by it by a man who was I think deranged
he was an anarchist but he had sort of
various confused ideas and Clemenceau
was coming out of his house one day and
I think it was in February 1919 and this
man was was sort of hiding behind a
pillar and rushed out and fired at him
several shots and several of them shot
struck Clemenceau one ball in fact
remained inside of him for the rest of
his life
Clemenceau was amazingly tough him he
was physically very brave and people who
went round to see him found him sitting
up the next day saying you know a
Frenchman who can't even aim shoot shoot
straight I'm ashamed of him but people
afterwards said although he seemed to
have made an amazing recovery that he
was tired or after that he never had
quite the same amount of cut powers of
concentration was he married
Clemenceau had been married I think
technically he he no longer was he
married an American woman
Clemenceau actually perhaps rarely among
French politicians at the time had spent
a lot of time in the United States he
went to the States in the eighteen early
1870s and actually taught at a girls
school somewhere up in the in the Hudson
Valley and learnt English quite well had
a great admiration for the United States
and while he was in the United States
married this by all accounts very pretty
young woman but I don't think she had an
easy time of in France she never learned
to speak French properly she was left
for long periods of time with Clement
Zoe's maiden aunts and a sort of gloomy
Chateau down in the Vonn day were rained
the whole time
and the marriage eventually broke up and
Clemenceau kept the children how long
was he in office Clemenceau was in
office from 1916 til the end of 1919
he'd been briefly Prime Minister before
the war and then he became Prime
Minister again in the middle of the
second middle of the first world war
Woodrow Wilson's the other man on this
cover yeah well who drove Wilson is is
the one I find the most puzzling I mean
he was in many ways an extraordinary
figure a great idealist very a man of
great vision he was in some ways a great
leader of the United States I think he
had a tremendous power for oratory and
he had an ability to inspire people but
he had these these failings he failed to
understand that people could oppose him
and not be wicked I mean he tended to
think if you disagreed with him there
was something wrong with you and it made
him not very good at the usual cut and
thrust and compromise of politics and I
think that in the end it was part of his
tragedy he refused at the very end to
compromise with the Republicans on his
treaty and it cost him very very dear
now the one man that's not on this cover
and it was a Council of four as you
point out was Orlando who was Orlando
Lando was the Prime Minister of Italy
and he was considered one of the big
four and and the main the body which
didn't made so many of the decisions
where is he in this picture I just have
to lean forward here
Orlando's at the very end on the
left-hand side the man with white hair
but he was an Italian politician he
survived in Italian politics which were
very complicated and he was very good at
making what the Italians called
combinati Oni and deals the Italians
were not a major power I mean they it
was really by courtesy they were
considered one of the big four but they
were not as powerful as Britain France
of the United States and they tended
only to talk when it was matters that
concerned them and so they came with a
very clear agenda and they tended not to
worry about anything much else what
happened to them before the conference
was over
well they got into a tremendous row they
had claims if we had come into the war
late and it basically came in looking
for the best deal for itself it thought
of joining either side in the end it
joined the Allies because the Allies
could promise it more and what the
Italians wanted was that greets
woth of the east coast of the Adriatic
what is today Croatia and Slovenia
Croatia and Bosnia as you go from north
to south and the italians wanted to
claim a lot of that on the grounds that
it had once been italian and there was
still italian communities living there
why they really wanted it was because
they didn't want any power across the
Adriatic that could be a menace to them
and the country that wanted it was the
new country of Yugoslavia that had just
emerged the Italians had been promised a
certain amount of that territory during
the war by the British and the French
but they wanted even more and so the
real trouble one of the real problems
and there were many problems at the
peace conference but one of the ones
that really blew up was when the Italian
claims were rejected by Woodrow Wilson
who said look I'm not giving you
territory which doesn't have Italians in
it I don't care what promises were made
during the war by the British and the
French that is not what I stand for I
stand for a different set of diplomacy
where people aren't given away against
their will to people who to be ruled
over by people of another ethnicity or
nationality and so the Italians in a
fury said alright we're working out and
it was a very crucial time of the peace
conference it was just around Easter
1919 as the German terms having got
ready so the Italians walk out which
leaves a real problem and is are there
going to be enough nations there to
enforce their will on Germany and so
there's a huge sort of Rao Woodrow
Wilson is furious and decides to make an
appeal directly to the Italian people he
believed that if he could speak directly
with Italian people the Italians would
see reason and so he issued an open
letter and unfortunately the Italian
populace by that point was in no mood to
see reason as a huge nationalist fervor
in Italy any rate eventually what
happened is the Allies made preparations
Britain France and the United States to
simply go on and try and make the treaty
with Germany anyway and the Italians
came back rather reluctantly but
relations remained very very bad
thirty-one nations you say attended this
who just determined who was a delegate
well it was any nation that had been an
ally or an associate during the First
World War what the nations who came
included all the various parts of the
British Empire Italy Belgium Portugal
was there
of latin-american countries Brazil for
example which had been on the American
side Japan China all these nations had
fought in the First World War on the
side of the Allies the nations who
didn't come and this was later on to be
an enormous point of controversy were
the ones who had defeated the defeated
nations expected that they would have
the usual sort of peace conference that
they'd had up to this point whether
defeated in the end the victors sat down
and hammered something out and this
never happened
who were they defeated the defeated
would Germany first of all it had been
the main linchpin in what we call the
Central Powers and then you had what had
been austria-hungary which by this point
had broken up and so you had a separate
little Austria and a separate Hungary
they both were among the defeated then
you had Bulgaria which had fought with
Germany and austria-hungary
and the final defeated nation was the
Ottoman Empire the Ottoman Turks who
controlled to what is today Turkey and
again most of the Arab Middle East and
none of those countries were invited to
participate in the actual discussion
nope they were not invited what happened
and this was really a mistake on the
part of the Allies the Allies assumed
that they would need a preliminary sort
of meeting to hammer out a common
position it took them so long to hammer
out a common position that by the time
they got it done and it really wasn't
done until the end of April 1919 but
they really didn't dare sit down with
the defeated nations because they
thought you know if we try and open the
whole thing again we'll never get a
peace and so they called the Germans the
Germans are the first to be cold call
them to Paris and basically said here
are your terms take it or leave it you
have two weeks to send us in writing any
comments you may have but we may not pay
any attention to them and the Germans of
course resented that bitterly World War
one was fought for how many years
started in the late summer of 1914 it
ended on November the 11th 1918 so it
was fought for four years and most
people thought it would go into a fifth
year and who was fighting against which
countries are fighting against each
other and who started it oh well who was
fighting against each other is easier
than who started it
the main Alliance was on the one hand
Britain France Russia and then later on
joined by the United States in 1917 but
Britain of course included the British
Empire
Canadians fighting Australians fighting
South Africans New Zealanders
Newfoundland is fighting Indians Indians
yeah large numbers of Indian troops came
to France and then as the war dragged on
various other countries joined Belgium
of course was involved right from the
beginning because it was the invasion of
Belgium that started the whole thing
Romania joined on the Allied side Greece
joined on the Allied side Japan which
was a British ally in those days joined
on the Allied side and China of course
so you had a whole coalition Serbia also
was was on the Allied side again it was
attacked right at the beginning on the
other side you had Germany Austria
Hungary Bulgaria and the Ottoman Empire
now who started it is is a much more
complicated question historians still
argue about it if you I tell my students
go to the library and see how many books
you have on the origins of the First
World War and see how many there are in
the origins of the Second World War
first world war ones go on forever at
the latest count I think there was
something like 21 thousand books in
English on who started the first world
war and that's because it's not clear I
think what historians the consensus now
is that Germany didn't perhaps
technically started but Germany had
created the atmosphere when she became
likely that German policies before 1914
had been so reckless that they had
helped to create an alliance against
Germany and they had helped to create an
atmosphere in Europe where really any
single incident would set it off and
what set it off was the assassination of
the Archduke at Sarajevo in the summer
of 1914 why would that set it off
the Archduke was the heir to the
Austrian throne and austria-hungary was
enraged by what they saw Serbian
nationalism Serbia by this point was an
independent country and the Serbs or at
least some Serbs were calling on the
large number of Serbs and Croats in fact
who lived within austria-hungary in a
sense to to join them they were
appealing to the Serbs inside
austria-hungary and so what Serbian
nationalism was to austria-hungary was a
threat to its very existence
if they gave way in the south and
allowed the Serbian areas and that
included parts of Bosnia which was under
Austrian control to join with Serbia
then they would face similar demands and
they were already already were facing
them from the poles and the north from
the Czechs from the Slovaks and so for
austria-hungary
Serbia was not just a menace and a
nuisance down on the south it was a
threat to the very existence of that
great multinational Empire and so when
their heir was assassinated in Sarajevo
the capital of Bosnia in 1914 the
Austrians saw an opportunity to stamp on
Serbia once and for all and they that
they didn't care about their Archduke II
was very unpopular and he was given a
miserable little sort of low-grade
funeral and back in Vienna but what they
wanted and they'd been talking about it
for some time was an opportunity to
polish Serbia off in 1914 what shape
were countries like Great Britain in and
the United States and of course France
where how did they fit in the world
well Brittany was the leading world
power it had the biggest Navy it had the
biggest empire and it was still the
leading world economic power the United
States was beginning to rival it in
economic terms but in 1914 the United
States was still not a military power it
did not he was building its Navy but it
still wasn't a major naval power and
it's its army it was tiny I mean I think
its army was smaller than that of
Italy's it was not yet translating its
enormous economic potential into
military potential I mean the Americans
so no need to do this France was a world
power but it was a world power with real
problems and the French had a big empire
in the French were very conscious of
themselves as a world power but I think
they're also very conscious that they
were not the power they had once been
one of the things that really worried
them was their economy which was more or
less stagnant if you look at the figures
their output wasn't going up whereas
that of Germany was going up
dramatically and that of Britain and
neuen States was going up the other
thing that really worried them was that
year after year there were more Germans
and Frenchmen more German infants will
be born every year than French infants
and so the potential for soldiers was
that much bigger in Germany and so the
French were very conscious that they
were slipping you tell me where I'm
wrong but reading your book you get the
impression that lloyd-george and Woodrow
Wilson and Clemenceau and others didn't
like each other at all I mean there's
constant harping back and forth they had
a funny relationship and yes they didn't
like each other I think I mean Lloyd
George got on with most people he was
one of these people who would have
furious trousers and then not bear a
grudge
Wilson was much more prickly and tended
once he conceived a dislike of someone
never really to get over it Clemenceau
didn't much like lo Jorge he felt he was
not a gentleman and for Clemenceau this
was important and felt he was not very
well educated Clement so didn't much
like Woodrow Wilson either I mean what
was his great joke he said at one point
in Paris he said I feel as if I'm
sitting between Napoleon on the one side
and Jesus Christ on the other and he
didn't mean either of those as a
compliment but you know they did have
fights I mean there was a point at which
Woodrow Wilson went white with anger and
said to Clemens I've never been so
insulted clemenceau had accused him of
being pro-german and and marched out of
the room there was a point at which
Lloyd George and clemenceau got into a
fight I think it was over who got what
in the Middle East and clemenceau ADA's
said challenged Lloyd George to a duel
which luckily Lloyd George didn't fight
because he would have been hopeless and
Clemenceau had fought duels in his time
but you know they developed a sort of
fellowship because they met day in day
out and they talked and we do have a
very complete record of their
conversations and they're quite touching
moments where they sit around and they
you know they just hashed out some
enormous problem then they talk to each
other than they say you know I have
trouble sleeping yes as Clemens so I do
- you know I'm worrying about this and
that and they compare notes and you know
in a way they understand each other
because nobody else has those pressures
and nobody else has to make those
decisions and nobody else has that
lonely sense of being right you know
that the one person in your country
who's making those decisions most
Americans think that they won World War
one that if it wasn't for America that
war wouldn't have ended like it did is
that true it's a hard one I mean I think
the war in a way was already being won
the British blockade of Germany was
really biting deep by this point in
Germany's capacity to wage war was being
hit very very hard and the Germans I
think were closer to the end of their
tether than we've realized I think where
the Americans made a huge difference is
that they came in they were fresh and it
was clear that there were more and more
of them coming not that many Americans
compared to the second world war
actually fought in the feminine a lot
foot but that their fighting was largely
at the end American casualties were
about the same as those of Australia's
in the First World War
but I think I don't know the Europeans
have always resented the American
sinking they won the first world war I
think the Americans tipped the balance
and they tipped it in a very decisive
way this picture here woodrow wilson
arriving in paris was this crowd there
to greet him or was to greet all the
people coming for the conference
no is to greet Wilson he popular Wilson
was enormous ly popular and he arrived
in Europe in 1918 December 1918 and it
was a Europe that was shattered by this
war I mean I think it's in a funny way
the First World War affects the
Europeans even more than the Second
World War I mean it was they had a sense
that their civilization had inflicted a
reparable damage on itself they'd lost
these millions of young men I mean it's
it's and men not just young men but men
of military age it's it's hard to
imagine I mean the French lost either
killed or wounded half the men of
military age a Age civilizations people
thought were collapsing austria-hungary
had gone Germany and had a revolution
that been a Russian Revolution and so
Wilson comes I think people see him as
the hope and a lot of people in Europe
really believed in his ideas that they
thought the League of Nations was a very
good idea now there was it's often being
portrayed and in some of the histories
as if there's this great gulf between
Europe and the United States the United
States has this view of a better world
and the Europeans will have none of it
and I just don't think it's true Wilson
was greeted as a savior huge crowds his
boat landed at Brest the the French port
and people who were there said virtually
every living being in Brest came out to
welcome him and as his train went to
Paris that night his doctor woke up in
the night about 3:00 in the morning
looked out and there were people French
people standing along the railway tracks
just watching the train go by you know
those are those tremendous hope and the
stories that in in you know battalion
peasant houses they had pictures of
Wilson and they would cross themselves
in front of the picture I mean this man
carried tremendous hopes and
expectations when he came to Europe and
the crowds that greeted him were
tremendously enthusiastic how much of
this did you know before you got into
writing this book was in your own
training I knew some of it I mean I knew
the outlines and I tended to take the
rather what then was the rather standard
view that it was a bad piece and people
you know
the Paris Peace Conference is full of
cynics who didn't really have any ideals
and as I read more and more I began to
change my ideas so some stuff I didn't
know I don't think I'd realized the
tremendous poll that Woodrow Wilson had
for the imaginations of Europeans I
don't think I understood that properly
at all League of Nations
14 points yeah how did they fit into all
this
and what were they well the 14 points
were among the various statements that
Woodrow Wilson had made during the war
after the United States entered about
what the United States and its its
allies were fighting for
did he make those all at once or did he
make them at different times he made
them at different times I mean there
were the 14 points which he made in
January 1918 and then there were the
four principles which he made slightly
later there were a number of speeches
great speeches he made in the course of
1917 and 1918 but I think it's the 14
points that really caught people's
imagination the most and in those 14
points don't ask me to remember them all
although I probably could but you got
them in your book I've got them
somewhere but the 14 points are about a
new way of running the world
but a new world order really that's what
they're about about a piece without
annexations of territories without
retribution about a just peace about
people's right to choose their own
rulers and that's often called national
self-determination which gets us into a
whole other sort of difficult area about
a League of Nations an association of
Nations which will find other ways of
settling disputes than going toward and
about an open diplomacy about things
being done more openly no more secret
deals no more secret promises which
Woodrow Wilson and many people felt had
got Europe into this mess League of
Nations what happened to that well it
was a noble idea a lot of people now
look at it as a failure and I don't
think we should because it was the first
time anything had been tried like this
what happened to the League of Nations
was it was set up and I think it made
well what it was set up to do was
provide collective security the idea was
that we'd like joining a club everyone
would join and then if anyone attacked a
member of the club everyone else in the
club would come to that members defense
the two mistakes I think it made
and it's easy to say this with hindsight
of course was that they didn't invite
the defeated Nations and immediately and
so Germany which had been told you know
New World Order's things going to be
different wasn't allowed to join the
League of Nations although it had to
sign a treaty the Treaty of Versailles
which Germany signed incorporated the
League of Nations that the very first
part of the treaty was actually the
Covenant of the League of Nations and
that was one problem and so the defeated
nations although they eventually joined
never really trusted the league they saw
it as a League of Victor's and the
second problem was the United States
didn't join that was a tragedy I think
you tell a story about Woodrow Wilson
going back to the United States in the
middle of this and speaking in Boston
yeah the home of Henry Cabot Lodge yeah
the senator who objected to the lega
Nations and led the Republicans against
it why did you mention that speech well
it was an important point I think it
reveals something about Woodrow Wilson's
way of dealing with his opponents it
wasn't it was a stupid thing to do Henry
Cabot Lodge didn't oppose the idea of a
league he wanted a different sort of
League and he would have I think been
prepared to talk about it and there were
a lot of people in the United States who
wanted a league of some sort but Woodrow
Wilson had made it quite clear that it
was going to be his league and he went
to Boston which was Henry Cabot Lodge
his hometown he Cabot Lodge it was the
senator from Massachusetts and he made a
speech there about the league in a sense
he's sort of throwing down the gauntlet
on Cabot Lodge his own home turf he'd
also told the Senate that he would
reveal the league to them first he
negotiated this in Paris he'd come back
for a very short trip to the United
States but instead of telling the Senate
about it he basically makes a public
speech in Boston and I just think was a
stupid move it alienated people
unnecessarily we start out by talking
about the fact that you're the
great-granddaughter of David Lloyd
George in your lifetime growing up when
was the first time that you knew that
that mattered I think it was the first
time I went to England when I was 10 and
it had never mattered to me before
because most people in Canada didn't
know who David Lloyd George was and I
didn't know much about him but I went to
England when I was 10 and I went to stay
with my grandmother and in Wales they
have these big cultural festivals called
Eisteddfod where people sing and they
have poetry contests and the Welsh are
very keen on poetry
I went with my grandmother my great aunt
and I suddenly rise and lots of people
coming up and talking to them and saying
you know how nice to meet you and is
this his great-granddaughter no you know
I didn't look like him at all so they
couldn't say that and I suddenly thought
you know this man must be somebody I
think that's when I first realized it
did you read a book about him at any
point finally enough I sort of resisted
reading books about him I think as I
heard so much about him for my family
and and you know as one does as a child
you think I don't really want to know
about this man I'm tired of hearing
about him and so I didn't read about him
till later I read a scarless memoir
written by my great uncle which was
pretty awful actually and then I did
start reading about him there's a very
great English historian who alas died
just last year called John Gregg who
wrote a wonderful multi-volume biography
of Lloyd George he never finished it
which which is the tragedy but I read
all of those as they came out and it
gave me a give me a greater I think
interest in him now why did your
great-uncle write a scurrilous book
about what was his brother his father I
think often my boy George's eldest son
had a very unhappy and difficult life
and I think it is difficult sometimes
being the son of a great man and I think
he was persuaded to write this book and
I think he later came to regret it I
mean he scarless well he wrote about the
affairs and I think you know most people
in the family knew about them but we
felt it shouldn't be discussed publicly
they remember in Westminster there's a
big statue of him or a small statue
because he wasn't big how big how tall
was he
I think she was about five foot six
that's what my mother remembers he was
quite small and apparently had very neat
little hands and neat little feet and
you know why would there be a statue
there I mean and what not every Prime
Minister of Great Britain has a statue
there they how do people in Great
Britain where do they put him on the
list of important people in their
history well probably not that far up
today but certainly after the first
world war they would have done there was
a list recently of a hundred Great
Britain's and I don't think he was on it
but there are always historians AJP
Taylor the great British historian
always said that in his opinion Lloyd
George was the greatest Prime Minister
of the 20th century and so I think he's
a sort of minority tastes you mentioned
two things when we started Ho Chi Minh
at the Ritz Hotel and pear
what was he doing there Ho Chi Minh was
it was a young obscure Vietnamese
nationalists at this point and Vietnam
was part of French Indochina and he'd
got involved in nationalist politics
which had made the French authorities
take an interest in him and he'd have to
leave and so he'd knocked about the
world he'd been a sailor he'd been this
in that I mean some of his early days
are a bit obscure but he'd ended up in
Paris as an assistant cook at the Ritz
and so during the Peace Conference
he drop a little petition and tried to
present it to the Peace Conference
asking for greater independence for his
little country of Vietnam as far as we
know it was never seen by any of the big
three Ho Chi Minh was not a name to be
reckoned with in those days you also
mentioned Lawrence of Arabia Lawrence oh
yeah and it's one of the reasons I got
so interested in all this Lawrence of
Arabia was there he was there and a
rather curious position he was there as
advisor to the Arab Dilek delegation led
by Faisal who was the son of the Sharif
of Mecca now where is he in this in this
photograph well if I was right in the
middle and Lawrence Arabia is standing
just to his right over there yeah right
there that's Lawrence wise was right
yeah Faisal is right the Faisal was
later on going to be the king of Iraq
interestingly enough and Lawrence of
Arabia was his advisor but Lawrence was
also being paid by the British and so
what he really was was a British agent
trying to push the Arabs in a direction
that Britain wanted why do we know so
much about Lawrence of Arabia oh I think
he fascinates people partly because he
was so mysterious Lowell Thomas the
great American journalist said Lawrence
has an absolute talent for backing into
the limelight
you know Lawrence always said I don't
want to be in the center of attention
but he often was and a lot of people who
written biographies of him and I think
he's friendly perennial II fascinating
you know he was mysterious all these
attempts to enlist in the RAF the Royal
Air Force and the Ironman dersu names he
was a brilliant scholar I mean it's just
one of those people who fascinate you
you mentioned all the characters I want
to show some of the pictures just to
give us a brief sketch of who they are
well the man at the top is Petrovsky
with all the hair and he was a great
pianist he was one of the great pianists
of his age he was also a Polish Patriot
and when Poland
jarick Poland which didn't exist from
the end of the 18th century until the
end of the First World War and
the war broke out Petrovsky said I will
devote all my energies to trying to
bring about the rebirth of Poland I
won't play the piano again until that
has happened and he became the first
Prime Minister of the reconstituted
Poland who is this fella right here I'm
trying to see myself sir Greece oh sorry
yes Venizelos vivent Vinay's alas if I
pronounced it correctly he was the Greek
Prime Minister an enormous ly appealing
character and he charmed people in Paris
he used to sit there and tell them
stories about how he'd fought for Greek
independence with a rifle across his
knees but he would sit there and read
classical Greek at the same time or he'd
read The Times of London and what George
really fell under his spell oughta
Turkey Ataturk
was an extraordinary man Turkey
everybody thought Ottoman Turkey was
down and out at the end of the first
world war it had lost its Arab
territories Turkey itself was due to be
pretty well carved up among the powers
and acetic said nothing doing and he
went into the interior of Turkey and he
summoned and he put together an army he
various Turkish nationalists joined him
he basically defeated the powers and
they had to tear up the original peace
treaty they'd made with Turkey and they
signed another one in Lausanne which
basically left Turkey as we see it today
who's this gentleman that's cousin
George cousin who was the epitome in
many ways and you can see it from the
photograph of a British aristocrat I
mean he came from a very upper-class
family he had a huge estate he'd gone to
Oxford he'd won all such surprises and
he became British Foreign Minister he
probably knew more about the world than
anyone else in the British government
extraordinary figure his great weakness
was that he had no sense of proportion
and so he'd worry about trifles as much
as he worried about the big issues who
would you like to meet of all these
people that you wrote about today if you
could oh that's a very difficult
question I guess I'd like to meet
Venizelos I mean he was apparently
absolutely fascinating Lawrence of
Arabia I don't know he was a very
difficult person to meet and could be
very prickly so I'm not sure I'd want to
meet him
Clemence I would love to have met he
could be absolutely charming I think as
a woman well I'm old enough and I'd be
quite safe but if I were a younger woman
you'd have to be a bit careful because
Clemenceau
a great ladies man hehe my grandmother
actually once got a lift from him she
was in Paris visiting her father and
Clemenceau was there and he said can I
give you a lift wherever you're going
and she said well how nice of you and
they got into his chauffeur driven car
and they were chatting away and my
grandmother spoke well he spoke English
and she spoke quite good French and I
don't know what language they were
speaking and he said do you like I have
to my grandmother who was about 23 said
oh I love it and so he pulled out these
series of postcards I think just filthy
postcards and my grandmother said really
she said I didn't know where to look she
said they were quite extraordinary and
he was a bit of an old rogue I think how
much in this book comes from just you
knowing stuff because of your family
very little I mean that's one of the few
things I knew and I guess I got a slight
flavor
my grandmother was there a bit and
unfortunate I never talked to my
great-aunt about it who sadly died in
the 1960s she was there much longer my
grandmother really wasn't all that
interested in in high policy so she
could give me a flavour of people I mean
she met Lawrence of Arabia and I said
what was he like one teasing she said I
don't remember much but he had a funny
handshake so you got a flavour but no
more I mean really pretty well
everything I got was just from reading
back to World War one how many people
were killed well the death toll it's
it's disputed probably 20 million if you
add in all the Russians who died in the
First World War and in the subsequent
Civil War it's very very high I mean
France lost 1.4 million men Germany lost
about 1.2 million Britain lost 800,000 I
mean these figures are so big it's it's
hard to almost believe in them where was
most of the fighting done most of the
fighting was done on the western well
there was a Western Front and a stand
front there's a lot of fighting over in
the Eastern Front between Germany and
austria-hungary on the one hand and
Russia but the fighting that we all know
about was the Western Front the trenches
that ran literally from the channel down
to the Swiss border through Belgium and
then down through France and that was
where the the real horrors that we
remember of the war were these terrible
terrible battles like Passchendaele and
the Battle of the Somme which you know
literally hundreds of thousands of men
would die and the front would move maybe
300 yards 400 yards was a dreadful
dreadful
battlefield you concluded
I'm wrong that the Treaty of Versailles
was not what caused world war two in
spite of what a lot of people think
today I did and I certainly didn't
believe this when I started out it was a
bad tree he liked a lot of people did
but you know I kept on thinking they
didn't they did the best job they could
have done I kept on asking myself all
right if you're gonna criticize him what
would you have done differently
would you have driven Germany down into
the ground and occupied Germany and
there wasn't the will to do that in 1918
I mean they'd already lost so many so
does the idea of going in and fighting
door to door in Germany was not
something that appealed so if you don't
drive Germany down to the ground you you
leave a very strong Germany at the heart
of Europe how do you deal with it and it
was a problem but I'm not sure that
anyone knew how to deal with it
including the Germans themselves and it
seemed to me also to say that something
that happened in 1919 is responsible for
something that happens 20 years later
well what about all the people in
between and their decisions and their
faith is I mean you have to look at that
as well I thought I wrote the figures
down but the reparations issues
throughout your book to whether or not
Germany was gonna have to pay a lot of
these country back this what was do you
remember what the total figure would
have been the total figure that was
asked from Germany in the end was
something like 32 billion dollars
how much did they actually pay before it
was over 4.5 billion why didn't they pay
the rest well the problem with the
reparations was that Germany never
thought it should pay anything so you
had an absolute I would say virtually
unanimous sense and generally we
shouldn't be paying any of this and so
there was no will on the part of the
German government to pay and the way the
reparations was structured it's slightly
technical but they were structured in
three sort of slices the first slice
which Germany had to pay right away was
I think about I'm trying to remember how
much it was I think it was about two
billion dollars and they did pay that
the second slice was a little bit larger
and they paid these and the second and
third slices they paid by issuing bonds
they didn't have to pay the second slice
until they paid the first slice and they
didn't have to pay the third slice which
was by far the biggest until they'd paid
the first two and so they really had
very little incentive to pay up because
they knew that the more they paid up the
more they'd have to pay
and so the German government simply
defaulted they said they couldn't pay
they said that you know they simply
couldn't do it and that was something
that was widely popular in Germany the
United States want countries out of this
know the United States came into the
peace conference with with really no
gains for itself in mind none none at
one point they were asked and they
considered taking over a mandate for
Armenia
that was discussed there was another
discussion of perhaps they take over a
mandate a sort of authority to run
Armenia under the League of Nations for
the area around Istanbul the famous
streets but there was no political
support in the United States for that
whatsoever and so the United States
really didn't have any territorial
claims what it did have was of course a
sense that you know America was now in a
very strong position and perhaps was a
good time to get into markets and
perhaps it was a good time to push
American exports but that was
understandable because in fact it was
what a great Britain won what did they
get
well Great Britain came into the Peace
Conference it had two very clear goals
it wanted to destroy German naval power
because that's what had menaced Britain
before the First World War in fact
that's very large part of what led to
the first world war and the British had
a navy they'd always wanted their navy
to be the equivalent of any two other
navies in the world because for Britain
the Navy was was its lifeline it was its
protection and its lifeline to all its
vast empire and to protect its trade and
they wanted to destroy the German Navy
and they did they basically that had
been done by the time the Peace
Conference open Germany had surrendered
its submarines and its surface fleet and
had surrendered them to the British and
so the German submarine fleet went to
the south of Britain and the German
surface fleet went up to Scapa Flow in
the Orkneys in Scotland and so the
British had done that second thing the
British wanted was more territory and
that's where Lord George the old liberal
suddenly becomes a real land grabber and
what they grab with big bits of the
Middle East they also wanted to make
sure that German colonies didn't go back
to Germany and the British on the whole
with a few exceptions didn't want the
colonies themselves what were they
colonies for Germany the colonies the
German colonies there was Tanganyika in
Africa German East Africa which did
become part of the British Empire
there were the Cameroon's and togo which
were divided between
in France and then further south that
was German Southwest Africa Namibia
today and that South Africa took over
you've got some of the components of the
British Empire now building their own
little empires and then there were some
islands in the South Pacific which
Australia New Zealand took over what of
Francois Francois did well France was
interested a bit in some of Germany's
colonies and so they got bits of German
colonies in Africa and of course they
got bits of the Middle East but Clemens
owes main interest was in protection
against Germany you know he was deeply
apprehensive of Germany he recognized it
was stronger than France and so what he
wanted was some form of protection what
some of his generals wanted and what
some of his conservatives were in his
government wanted was actual territory
in fact some of them even went so far as
to talk about breaking Germany up into
its component parts Germany was a very
new country it had only really come into
existence in 1871 and so some people in
France said well why not have a Bavaria
again and why not have a pressure again
why not have some small estates and that
wasn't odd I mean Woodrow Wilson and
what George wouldn't have gone for it
and there was some talk of taking the
east bank of sorry the west bank of the
Rhine River which was German territory
but the Rhine makes a wonderful natural
barrier and so people some people in
front said why don't we take the west
bank of the Rhine make it proud of
France or perhaps make it into an
independent state and Woodrow Wilson and
Lloyd George wouldn't go for that they
said look at the west bank of the Rhine
is German if you take it away you will
create problems with German nationalism
it'll just cause disruptions endlessly
in Europe until Germany is reunited and
so what Clemens has settled for was
control of German coal mines in an area
for 15 years because Frances coal mines
had been destroyed by Germany and a
guarantee from the British and the
French that if Germany attacked France
Britain and France would come to Frances
Britain and the United States would come
to Frances defense this was known as the
anglo-american guarantee and for
clemenceau he felt that offered him
enough security by the way down the
League of Nations the Americans never
approved that and you say in your book
that it effectively ended in 1939 but
didn't really go out of business 246
yeah but where was it at the time how
many people did belong
Nations I think it was about 26
countries and all because various
countries joined I'm in Germany
eventually joined as time went on and
Soviet Union eventually joined who
wanted the league army that was friends
the French said the league should have
its own army they thought it could be
used I think mainly against Germany if
Germany got out of line and the
Americans would not have that neither
with the British they didn't want a
permanent standing League army go back
to what we had in 1919 this Paris Peace
Conference the Versailles Treaty was
signed what today in this world that
we're dealing with as a result of what
happened there well what's today a
result is well Yugoslavia in a way was a
result but that no longer is with us and
then Czechoslovakia is no longer with us
while the boundaries in the center of
Europe are a result of that what is
probably the one that we noticed most
today is Iraq Iraq was a product of the
Peace Conference team and I mean in
Palestine Palestine as well the Jewish
homeland which then became the State of
Israel tell the story about how
Palestine became the Jewish homeland
back in those years
okay well during the first world war
there was a lot of talk about a Jewish
homeland and by this point there's a
World Zionist movement and Zionists
mainly in Europe there wasn't much
support for Zionism among American Jews
at this point argued they had to have
their own homeland that without their
own homeland they would never be safe
living in as a minority and so there was
a lot of talk about this and gradually
the British came around to supporting
this idea now they did so partly for
reasons of sentiment Lord George had
grown up on the Bible and so in Balfour
who was then his foreign secretary and
so they felt that this whole idea of the
Jews going back to their ancient
homeland was was something that appealed
enormous ly to them but I think much
more important was they felt it would
help them during the war they felt that
world Jewry as they called it in those
days was quite a powerful force that if
they could win it over to their side it
would make a difference in Germany where
a lot of Jews lived it might hamper the
German war effort it would also make a
difference in North America among the
Jewish communities in North America and
so I think really for reasons of the war
much more than the sentiment although
the sentiment was there they decided to
support the Jewish homeland they very
carefully and this was the Balfour
Declaration
which was written by valpha the British
Foreign Secretary to Lord Rothschild
they very carefully did not mention a
Jewish state or nation they simply said
a homeland for the Jews in Palestine and
like the Zionists themselves they didn't
really think the Arabs living in
Palestine would mind and they simply
thought they were negligible force who
didn't have any particular nationalism
or any particular views on things so
there were 700,000 Arabs there in
Palestine at the time yeah and how many
Jews lived there back in those you know
50 or 60,000 the Jews were less than 10
percent or about 10 percent of the
population now some of them were the
descendants of Jewish communities that
had been there right from the Diaspora
the original Diaspora after the fall of
the temple in the 1st century AD but
some were European Jews who had moved
back to Palestine before the first world
war in this hopes of recreating a Jewish
homeland but the Jews were very much in
a minority in 1918 1919 when the war
ended the Arabs it is true were not
particularly organized I mean a lot of
them were farmers and didn't really have
a strong sense but even in 1919 you can
see signs that not all Arabs are going
to be happy about this
another part of what you talk about in
here is we deal with today is Lebanon
Syria the Bekaa Valley where they
trained a lot of terrorists really yeah
all that how did that all come about and
today the Syrians I guess we feel they
control Lebanon in one way or the other
yeah well this the Syrians the French
got Lebanon and Syria and they broke
away a bit of what the Syrians the
Syrians basically consider and still do
I think that Lebanon is part of what
should be a greater Syria the French
created Lebanon partly to protect their
own interests and partly to protect the
Christian communities in Lebanon who
they felt would otherwise be submerged
in a much larger Muslim population these
Syrians really never forgot this and
have always felt a sense of bitterness
about it which I think helps to explain
serious ambitions today Syrians of
course also look southwards and consider
that Palestine is properly Syrian as
well and so you have a Syria which
really has never got over what happened
at the end of the first world war and
Iraq you mentioned as being a result of
this 1919 treaty Iraq as Iraq was was
not really and it never
country I mean unless you go back to the
cogniser I mean which is a long long way
back I mean Iraq was was a series of
provinces of the Ottoman Empire and
there was Mosul in the north where the
British suspected with good reason there
was a lot of oil and then in the middle
you had the whole area around Baghdad
the valleys of the Tigris and Euphrates
and then in the South you had a whole
province around Basra province to the
South had always been heavily influenced
by Shi Islam and had lots of connections
with with the Persians in Iran
well Persia as it was known in those
days the area around Baghdad tended to
be fairly Arab but when you got up to
the north you had a lot of Assyrians who
were Christians and you also had of
course a Kurdish majority and so what
the British did for their own purposes
would throw together three provinces
which had very little in common simply
because they wanted a sort of Block in
that part of the Middle East to control
the oil to protect their routes out to
India overland and also to keep the
French or anyone else from getting it
but what they did was create a country
which really had very little of the
basis of what we think make a country
there was no national sentiment to speak
of in Iraq 30 chapters 570 pages you
dedicate this to two people named
McMillan who are they
my parents Robert Leonard which is a
Welsh name they were absolutely heroic
during us a lot of my family and friends
read it but my parents read every single
word they were absolutely wonderful in
fact they probably read every single
word a couple of times and so I think
they deserve the dedication what do they
do my father is a retired doctor and my
mother is a very energetic woman who is
a great gardener great conservationist
always busy organizing to save something
or other I don't mean this frivolously
because I think she does a fantastic job
so why would they spend all that time
reading your book well they're the most
loyal parents I mean they have five
children they think we are all terrific
they back us and everything we do I mean
it's one of us writes a book then they
will read every would they're absolutely
terrific where did you get your
education in Canada mainly but I went to
high school in England for a couple of
years which which was really interesting
and then I went to the University of
Toronto where they had and still have a
wonderful history program and then I
went to Oxford and did my graduate work
there
so I've been very lucky and what are you
teaching now and where I'm teaching at
the University of Toronto
I teach international relations I teach
a course in the history of the Cold War
how did it come about that Richard
Holbrooke former UN Ambassador the
United States wrote the foreword for
your book that was so nice of him that
my editor at Random House is also
editing a book that he's doing and he
heard about my book I think from her and
said he'd like to see it even before it
was published because it dealt with some
of the stuff he was planning to deal
with and so she sent him along a coffee
and he liked it and she said well if
you'd like it would you mind writing an
introduction and he said sure which I
think was the most generous thing to do
and and he's written a very very nice
introduction how's the reaction been as
you travel around do the bookstores talk
to people are you surprised about any
reaction you're getting on this book no
most of the questions are what I would
expect and people ask really good
questions you know they do want to know
how we got to here but I've had two
questions recently which are rather
similar and it I think says something
about what's happening today and they
are white or the French hate us
Americans so much which I find
interesting I'm it's not really the
subject of my book but maybe some of
what happens and explains it but I I
suspect you know that this reflects
what's been happening recently the
debate over the you know UN resolutions
on Saddam Hussein and so on that
surprised me a little bit we are out of
time there's so much more to talk about
Margaret Macmillan has been our guest
this is what the book looks like it's
Paris 1919 the Treaty of Versailles
thank you very much for joining us thank
you